[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ und
sahen wie raesfeld heute dreht sich bei
uns alles rund um das thema einschulung
der jedes jahr ja eigentlich letztes
jahr schon freud ist auch jetzt schon
immer aber dieses jahr betrifft uns auch
denn samira ist schon so groß die kommt
im september in die schule und setzt
sich schon schulranzen ausgesucht genau
geht fleißig in die vorschule in showrun
sind hand so wie ich damals und wir
werden den kann ich dann auch mit tanzen
beim schulranzen tanz cool
also lass mal so und jedenfalls haben
wir zu diesem anlass jetzt noch eine
torte gemacht im letzten jahr habe ich
eine schulranzen torte gemacht eine 3d
schulranzen torte und der schulranzen
sieht so aus wie meiner vor nicht allzu
langer zeit
ich war ja auch mal ein kleines kind
jedenfalls ist es auch eine richtig
schöne torte
dieses jahr haben wir es ein bisschen
bunter gestaltet und haben jetzt hier
eine torte mit verschiedenen
gegenständen die man eben bei der
einschulung brauchen genau da ist ein
zettel und da steht drauf zur
einschulung von samira in lateinische
ausgangsschrift dann der bleistift ein
paar büroklammern farbstifte ich habe
den hausaufgabenheft damit du dann ein
tragen kannst zahlen buchstaben also im
prinzip alles was man für die schule
braucht genau richtig toll oder gefällt
dir und in seinem lieblings geschmack
nämlich ist es eine erdbeertorte und bei
der videoproduktion wurden wer
unterstützt von scout und zwar gibt es
am ende nämlich richtig tolle
schulranzen für aus in frankenthal aus
frankenthal wir haben sie nicht lumpen
lassen
private angerufen wir haben ja bei uns
im endeffekt immer wieder an und jedes
jahr
und die lassen sich nicht lumpen wir
haben uns wirklich so ganzen verfügung
die wir verlosen genau und es wird
richtig schön also bleibt am besten dran
also los geht's mit der torte ich habe
mir bereits gestern etwas vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich aus dem tech basics
meinen rührteig gemacht den mit ein paar
mandeln verfeinert und da findet ihr das
rezept bereits auf meinem blog möchte
ich mich um die richtig leckere füllung
kümmern
ich mache jetzt einerseits eine vanille
buttercreme das ist eine
französische buttercreme und ich werde
noch eine frucht einlage machen aus
erdbeeren das sind so miraß lieblinge
etwa vorlage und vanille buttercreme die
apa frucht einlage oder frucht einlagen
allgemein mache ich sehr gerne weil man
dadurch wirklich die früchte haltbar
machen kann
die werden nicht matschig aber sie
schmecken einfach nach purer frucht und
die französische buttercreme passt da
wirklich perfekt mit dazu und ich finde
sie schmeckt auch gar nicht so sehr nach
butter sondern schmeckt richtig schön
frisch jetzt werde ich erst einmal die
faktenlage zu bereiten dafür habe ich
jetzt die erdbeeren über nacht aufgetaut
ich nehme der tiefgekühlte erdbeeren
weil ich dann einfach personal
unabhängig will die werden dann püriert
und weil sie sehr viel eigene
feuchtigkeit schon haben geht es nur
noch ein bisschen wasser mit dazu
zitronensaft und ein bisschen acker und
dann wird die mischung zwei minuten lang
aufgekocht das fruchtpüree verteidigt
dann in 320 cm kringe und die werden
dann später eingefroren und das
grundrezept dazu und das ausführliche
video findet ihr natürlich auch schon
auf meinem blog
jetzt werde ich nicht um die
französische buttercreme kümmern auch
dafür gibt es bereits ein grundrezept
das heißt hier geht's jetzt ein bisschen
schneller
die gerade jetzt mit dem zucker mit dem
salz und mit dem man extrakt in der
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion oder
auch einfach über dem warmen wasserbad
erhitzt und zwar auf 85 grad und das
ganze mache ich jetzt auch studie fährt
damit hier drinnen kein rührei entsteht
jetzt fährt die maschine die
geschwindigkeit herunter sobald die 60
grad erreicht habt und zwar kommt es
daher das ist die sicherheitsfunktion
das heißt ab 60 grad sind die man kann
sich verbringen und dann muss man hier
oben einfach diese taste drücken
hohe geschwindigkeit fährt wieder hoch
nachdem die eier kriegen dann fünf
minuten auf 85 grad erhitzt wurde habe
ich sie jetzt kalt gerührt das heißt es
dauert so etwa 20 bis 25 minuten bis die
creme dann etwa 20 bis 25 grad erreicht
hatte jetzt streiche ich sie durch ein
sieb das müsst ihr nicht könnt ihr aber
machen
so können eventuelle rückstände der eier
einfach entfernt werden und dann habe
ich die masse unter die butter die habe
ich jetzt schon maximal schaumig gerührt
dh ich habe sie so einfach fünf bis zehn
minuten lang die weiche butter mit einem
schneebesen glatt gerührt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte bereits füllen
dafür ziehe ich jetzt den abgekühlten
tortenboden auf einen torten retter
[Musik]
ich setze die torte jetzt auf eine
tortenplatte die habe ich jetzt einfach
zugeschnitten auf etwa 26 zentimeter
unter stress ich jetzt ein bisschen von
der mutter kind drauf so dass einfach
der erste tortenboden schön anklebt es
kommt der erste boden drauf
[Musik]
dann ein bisschen torten creme und
darauf setzt sich dann die frucht
einlage
da kommt noch mal ein bisschen torten
creme drauf und so fühle ich die gesamte
torte
[Musik]
und bevor ich die torte jetzt schön
glatt streichen planstelle ich sie jetzt
für etwa eine halbe stunde bis stunde in
den kühlschrank
so wird sie schön fest den top freitag
jetzt drauf gesetzt damit die torte
einfach schön flach und gerade wird die
kühe zeit kann ich jetzt perfekt nutzen
und schon mal ein bisschen dekoration
vorbereiten ein einstellungs vater
braucht natürlich auch stifte daher
werde ich jetzt hier die stifter
modellieren
ich nehme jetzt dafür etwas modul
irische balladen wie lässt sich super
gut geschnitten und auf den formen und
die mir doch ganz von alleine wieder
fest ich habe ich jetzt etwas weißer
modelle schokolade gelb eingefärbt alle
anderen farben gibt es bereits und die
werde ich jetzt zu einem langen strang
ausrollen und er sollte so etwa ein
zentimeter dick sein
so habe ich eben doch ein sind den
statiker stifter und das bisschen zu
vereinfachen nämlich jetzt erstmal nur
die hälfte
und jetzt schön gleichmäßig und ich
nehme jetzt gleich diese teig hölzer
einfach zur hilfe dann würde ich
wirklich schöne gleichmäßige stifter
hinbekommen so legt jetzt den strang
dazwischen und da kann ich schauen ob
sie bereits einen zentimeter dünn ist
und jetzt vorm ich sie immer weiter und
dann sehe ich irgendwann okay ein center
mir das erreicht und sie sind schon
gleich bis
[Musik]
und jetzt schneide ich einfach
unterschiedlich lange stücke ab damit
die stifte nicht alle gleichmäßig lang
sondern wirklich unterschiedlich lang
werden
[Musik]
jetzt dürften die stifter antrocknen das
ist auch immer ganz wichtig weil man
dann einfach viel viel einfacher
weiterarbeiten kann
jetzt nehme ich hier einen stift und ein
kleines stückchen holz farbe
also ich hab da einfach ein bisschen was
gemischt braun gelb blau als einfach
alles ein bisschen zusammengemischt ein
modell ihr schokolade
ihr könnt auch blüten wahrzunehmen und
jetzt werde ich hier vorne bei dem einen
stift als ist muss wirklich ganz gerade
sein der abschluss ein bisschen das
wegschneiden
damit dieses kleines stück braun und
auch wegschneiden und das wird ja jetzt
die holz spitze da kommt jetzt etwas
kleber dran wirklich mit ganz wenig wie
bearbeiten damit der einen seite nicht
raus gewählt und dann die zwei
schnittflächen zusammenfügen und das
ganze jetzt spitz zu formen mit den
fingern
so erkennt man jetzt schon mal den stift
jetzt wird natürlich da oben noch mal
die spitze weg geschnitten damit die
bunte spitze dran kann also vorher noch
ob es den spitz formen
dann kann man den kleinen rest neben den
eben weg geschnitten haben
[Musik]
mit etwas kleber ankleben
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig damit das
stift hier nicht so aussieht dass ihr
das ganze wirklich zwischen den fingern
helmut herold und somit eine schöne
gleichmäßige spitze entsteht
[Musik]
und manche stifte werde ich genau
verkehrt herum auf leben das heißt sie
finden brauche ich dann auch noch mal
die fläche so dass das ganze so wie hier
wie ein richtiger stifter aussieht und
dafür nimmt er dann einfach noch mal ein
bisschen von dem brown-forman zu einer
kleinen kugel lebt diese kugel mit etwas
kleber an und drückt so schön flach und
stark kommt noch mal ein kleiner punkt
ein und schon ist auch die rückseite des
stiftes
[Musik]
hier sind die stifter fertig und ich
habe jetzt hier noch den langen und zwar
ist der kleinen stift der bekommt
natürlich eine schwarze mähne und
deswegen auch hier hinten den schwarzen
punkt
[Musik]
für hinten habe ich mir jetzt überlegt
das sagt doch im radiergummi also im rat
hole drankommt und darf ich jetzt
einfach ein bisschen von dem pink und
gelb gewünscht habe ich jetzt so ein
leichtes orange das würde zu einer kugel
geformt hinten drauf geklebt
[Musik]
und um diesen und allen randhir zu
verdecken habt ihr etwas schwarzem
modelliermasse ausgerollt die schneide
ich jetzt zu und setzte damit metallic
farben ein bisschen einfärben und
einfach dann vom problem
[Musik]
zweimal in der grundschule einen weißen
fleck stück braucht würde ich jetzt nur
sagen schreibe ich noch drauf
[Musik]
doch einen kleinen witz effekt auf die
wäschespinne mit etwas kakaopulver die
stifter können jetzt schon mal
antrocknen ich werde jetzt mit der torte
weitermachen
ich werde jetzt ein bisschen zu
schneiden damit die torte ein bisschen
kleiner wird als die tortenplatte das
heißt einfach mit einem schönen scharfen
messer und dann streiche ich rundherum
die restliche buttercreme
[Musik]
dort ist jetzt schön glatt gestrichen
und steht jetzt noch mal kühl für etwa
eine halbe stunde bis stunde
und jetzt kann ich noch ein paar
dekorelemente erstellen dafür nehme ich
wieder modelliert schokolade da könnt
aber auch von dort zum beispiel nehmen
und werde jetzt 3 mm dünn ausrollen und
dann buchstaben zahl ausschließen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich ein bisschen weißes
blüten passte bereits weist die rolle
ich jetzt ganz schön aus und zwar auf
wetters becker stärke und da wird dann
später sein papier draus gemacht und
eben auch drauf geschrieben
[Musik]
und die restliche buyten passte rolle
ich jetzt drei millimeter dünn aus und
zwar wird es jetzt die grundlage für das
hausaufgabenheft
[Musik]
zuvor lag in dem ich einfach einen
zettel und kann jetzt dieses papier her
dem papier grundlage aussprechen
[Musik]
und aus gelber modische collage also die
habe ich gelb eingefärbt mit passenden
farbe kann ich jetzt noch den umschlag
machen das heißt den muss ich jetzt
doppelt so groß ausrollen
[Musik]
kann ich das weiße papier hier ein
kleben einfach auf beiden seiten
bestreichen und dann las ich hier immer
so einen kleinen brand
so etwa millimeter breit dass sie dann
später ganz hübsch aus
[Musik]
dann öffnet orten räder setzen und mit
hilfe von zwei tätern oder zwei tellern
oder anderen gegenständen wenden und
damit die komplett gesperrt
[Musik]
als nächstes habe ich jetzt hier ein
kleines weißes schild bereits
ausgestochen
einfach aus blüten passte hier habe ich
etwas blauem oder schokolade
da klebe ich das weiß jetzt drauf und
wollen wir dass das namens etikett
das wird jetzt auch ausgestochen oder
einfach mit einem messer ausgeschnitten
und das blau soll einfach ein bisschen
größer sein und dann kläre ich das ganze
hier drauf
[Musik]
und lass es kurz antrocknen und jetzt
fehlen nur noch die büroklammern und die
habe ich hier auch schon vorbereitet ein
paar und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür auch
modelliermasse blüten passte egal
irgendetwas was einfach schön aushärtet
also von allein geht er nicht sondern
fordernd mit cnc pulver zum beispiel
oder von dort mit blüten passte
verknetet oder eben modelliert
schokolade und dann nehme ich jetzt so
kleine stücke kommen sie zu einer langen
dünnen rolle es geht am besten auf etwas
holz da rutscht das nämlich nicht so
sehr
[Musik]
dann ein kleines stück schon mal rein
formen also abknicken dann ein weiteres
mal abknicken
so hat man schon mal den inneren teil
und dann noch mal die große schleife
[Musik]
die torte es ist schön glatt die stelle
ich kurz zur seite
die ware eben in der kühlung jetzt habe
ich hier von wand bereits weich gebettet
ich habe jetzt drei päckchen erdbeere
genommen und ein päckchen weiß damit
einfach ein bisschen heller wird und
erdbeere passt natürlich geschmacklich
sehr gut so und auch optisch das auch
echtes etwa marc mit drin und es
schmeckt im prinzip so wie die fritz
kaubonbons also sehr lecker und das
werde ich jetzt hinauf fahren und dann
über die torte darüber legen
[Musik]
und damit der vom landgut haftet
bespricht die torte jetzt mit etwas back
trends bleiben legte über den
ausfuhrstopp drüber
die von der decke und dann wird sie
darüber gerollt und glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
dort ist jetzt schön glatt und ich habe
auch hier ein weiteres skateboard mit
dunkelgrün überzogen ich habe dann
einfach drei päckchen grün mit einem
päckchen schwarz vermischt und hpc
praktisch eine tafel kreide
da wird jetzt die torte draufgesetzt
jetzt kann ich die torte dekorieren das
heißt die ganzen einzelteile die ganzen
deko elemente werden jetzt hier drauf
gesetzt dieses blatt papier habe ich
jetzt übrigens noch bemalt genauso wie
das hausaufgabenheft einfach mit
lebensmittelfarbe stiften und jetzt wird
einfach alles schön drauf gesetzt und
was ich an kleben kann klebe ich dann
eben mit sv am klever
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte fertig unser mira
wie gefällt dir
also wir werden sie jetzt mal
anschneiden
ja es tut mir manchmal schon wird fortan
zu schneiden aber naja man muss trotzdem
ich schneide jetzt hier vorne malawi kam
es am irak-krieg blaue bänder über die
torte herfällt
[Musik]
die saison ist immer auch ein sell
alabama wird
danke
ich glaube dass das messer zu stecken
bleibt geht auch nur beim motiv dort ne
[Musik]
jetzt aber ich würde gerne dieses stück
fürs foto aufhebens heißt kann ich mir
noch intelligenter noch ein stück weg
jetzt dein stück gestern ist auch jetzt
schon mal cool den gesundheit marius
schon mal riesige ja schon da bleiben na
klar ich habe schon eine maxi probieren
ist ja immerhin eine torte man sieht
hier ist der ist ganz ganz wichtig finde
manchmal sind das motiv tolga vorzeichen
die partie trocken
da ist richtig war ich richtig weit und
diese pilotanlage richtig probier jetzt
probiere mal richtig saftig süß bin ich
ganz ehrlich nicht so abrufen wenn wir
ganz wenig liegt den erdbeer fondant ich
auch geschmeckt mich wie maurer aber ich
habe gesagt frites und wir haben hier
vor ihn auch schon diskutiert ich fand
das schrecklich fred und man könnte
sagen wir mal ganz ehrlich das ist ein
wunder wo ich einfach nicht mehr was ist
aber gemacht haben roger eben beim
zubereiten nicht dabei ich habe den etwa
von und mit einer packung weiß gemischt
mit ein bisschen heller werden nicht so
mädchen rosa und deswegen schmeckt ein
bisschen schwächer nach erdbeere aber
trotzdem sehr gut
er steht neben der will auch mal
probieren mama mama und ich bin ich
finde diese torten vor allem sellector
weil ich in die frucht einlage einfach
keinen zusätzlichen zucker gebe
das heißt ich habe die pure frucht und
habe sie einfach schön konserviert schön
praktisch auch in der torte drin und die
sieht auch er jedenfalls nach ein zwei
tagen noch ansehnlich aus weil die
erdbeeren eben nicht formation
der jubilar nicht los ein obstsalat
tisch geklettert
gleich wenn man das foto gemacht haben
nicht so gut bei uns kann man vom boden
müssen kein problem ja mora durch gar
nicht was ich kann über frucht einlagen
gesagt ich hab's ganz gut ich habe es
gemerkt aber ihr habt sehr gehört und da
da passt deswegen die vanille
buttercreme sehr gut dazu einfach da
hört man diese frucht die puppe und die
vanille buttercreme das gleich alles
sehr gut aus ich glaube ich brauche gar
nicht weiterreden morath sowieso nicht
so dass ich gar nichts mehr wartet schon
gespannt darauf also ein bleistift essen
kann die kleinen lässt in ruhe hier ja
auch gut okay das gewinnspiel jetzt noch
zum gewinnspiel genau
also falls ihr diese torte so nach
machen wollt empfehle ich euch sehr
denn sie ist sehr lecker sieht gut aus
und geht im prinzip ganz einfach mit ein
bisschen zeitaufwand jetzt gehen wir zum
gewinnspiel
hier stehen die gewinn preise wurden von
scout zur verfügung gestellt zu gewinnen
gibt es vier schulranzen und setzt die
schulranzen sind alle vier teile ich das
heißt man hat einen schulranzen mit
dabei einen turnbeutel ein schlamper
mädchen und ein voll ausgestattetes
mäppchen mit allen farbstiften hier ist
der erste der hier heißt scouts anigo
das heißt mit fußball motiv ich habe mir
den zweiten das ist eine ganz neue und
genius in pretty rost auch wirklich
party oder löschen
ja mir den scout alpha und zwar erst des
api dolphins und hier noch der vierte
und zwar ist es auch der scout alpha im
motiv sek das sondereinsatzkommando mit
polizei und falls ihr jetzt einen dieser
fair schulranzen gewinnen möchtet dann
schreibt uns einfach auf facebook
youtube oder instagram und zwar verlosen
wir einen schulranzen auf instagram
einen auf facebook und 2 auf youtube
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
welchen schulranzen ihr gewinnen möchtet
und wir werden euch dann schriftlich
benachrichtigen und zwar nächsten
samstag könnt ihr auf der facebook seite
von mir vorbeischauen da könnt ihr auch
vorbeischauen wenn ihr nicht bei
facebook angemeldet seid und könnt da
dann einfach die gewinner sehen und ihr
dürft dann unter der e mail adresse
die menschen geben wir dann einfach
nächste woche samstag bekannt dass fast
50 schon als ich drück euch auf jeden
fall die daumen
das los entscheidet das heißt wir werden
eine lust machen und das los gewinnt und
jetzt würde ich mal sagen falls ihr
rezept nach machen wollt geht auf
cellestis blog.de das stets noch mal
ganz genau und ich will die torte echt
schön stadt jetzt auch gleich ein
stückchen erdbeertorte ab und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen viel erfolg beim gewinnspiel
und bis zum nächsten mal viel spaß in
der schule viel spaß in der schule und
will gleich noch die anderen videos
anschauen wollt liegt so genau denn ich
werde noch eine schutzhütte basteln und
ihr dürft euch zu schauen
bis zum nächsten mal klappt als kind
hätte ich mich für wahrscheinlich hätte
ich mich zwischen den ich habe glaube
ich denke werde ich mit roten nelken
linke alte naja kind muss mal sein
[Musik]